So earlier this week, Donald Trump's attorney,
Rudy Giuliani, tested positive for coronavirus
and now another Trump attorney general, Ellis
has tested positive as well.
These are the primary to Trump lawyers who
have been waging this completely pointless
and bogus, baseless war to overturn the election
results based on imaginary voter fraud.
Jonathan Suan from Axios reporting on the
story, tweeting that President Trump's lawyer,
Jenna Ellis, has informed associates she has
coronavirus.
Multiple sources tell Axios stirring West
Wing fears after she attended a senior staff
Christmas party on Friday.
So a few different things here.
No.
One, is this surprising?
You know that she's not been taking precautions.
She's not been staying home.
She's not been avoiding indoor crowds.
She's not been wearing a mask.
She and Rudy Giuliani have been flying around
the country daily in a pandemic since the
election, during the worst period we've had
since the beginning of the pandemic.
And also attending at least, Janet Ellis did
a White House party and other larger events
there frequently massless at these so-called
hearings and events.
So Rudy got it.
Janet got it.
And now there's panic at the White House because
she was with a huge swath of White House staffers
on Friday.
And that may end up becoming another one of
these super spreader events.
She reportedly had no mask there, and it's
all a complete and total mess.
Now, of course, I wish no one ill.
I hope she recovers even though she's part
of the problem.
I'd never wish illness or death upon anyone.
What I want to mention is that there is something
sort of poetic about the virus that they ignored
and didn't deal with.
Now shutting down their harebrained, ill advised
attempts to overturn the results of an election
that Donald Trump simply lost partially because
of his his mishandling of the virus by infecting
his legal team.
I'm not saying it's karma.
I'm not saying it's divine intervention.
I'm just saying there's something ironic,
poetic, whatever.
That part of the reason Trump lost is his
his mishandling of the virus.
That same virus is now what is going to interfere
with Trump making a legal case that he should
be the winner anyway, despite having lost
now that Rudy is sideline General Ellis a
sideline, does this sort of naturally force
the voter fraud nonsense, the hearings, the
legal filings, the kind of peter out, or are
they going to try to push it remotely via
Zoome?
One report is that Rudy sometime this week
is going to be joining another one of these
hearings remotely from his hospital room.
Now, by the way, that's a whole other issue.
Some leaked, I guess you would call them,
exchanges between Rudy Giuliani and Trump's
doctor have been reported on.
And the allegation is that Trump's doctor
called Rudy and said, Rudy, go to the hospital
when Rudy tested positive and Rudy said, I
feel fine.
Why would I don't I don't want to go to the
hospital.
And Trump's doctor reportedly told Rudy, listen,
Rudy, just go.
We can get this dealt with in three days by
giving you the same treatment Trump got.
And presumably what this means is if you take
someone and you monitor them immediately,
you monitor their oxygen levels, you scan
them regularly at the sign of any decreased
and any type of any concerning vital signs.
You immediately deal with that so that the
body can continue fighting the virus.
There's no question is the point that if everybody
could get the treatment that Trump got and
that now Rudy Giuliani is getting just by,
hey, I'm going to check myself into a hospital
and get top treatments and best doctors and
all of that way more people would survive.
And we know that intuitively.
And it appears as though they're saying it
to Rudy in uncertain terms.
We can deal with this in three days if we
do what we did with Donald Trump.
And monitoring you for 72 hours wouldn't probably
apply to everybody, but it would save a lot
of lives if everybody could get that.
But coronavirus causing the end of this absurd
campaign to overturn the results of an election
that Trump lost, in part because he ignored
the virus early on.
That really is something.
I mean, you know, what they said was 15 cases
that would soon be zero back in April has
now infected Trump.
Trump's son, Don Jr., Trump's other son, Barron
Trump.
Don Junior's girlfriend, Kimberly Guilfoyle,
Trump's personal personal lawyer, his campaign
lawyer, his press secretary, a bunch of Republican
senators and on and on and on.
And I caught a discussion on right wing in
a right wing Internet forum yesterday where
right wingers were suspicious about why is
it that when prominent Democrats get the virus,
it isn't covered by the so-called fake news
media now?
The reason for that is that it's mostly prominent
Republicans that are getting the virus because
Democrats are taking the virus more seriously,
imagine at this point, at this stage of the
game, having the lack of ability to reflect
on something like that and coming away with
the idea that the media covers up prominent
Democratic covid cases.
Now, it's that it's mostly prominent Republicans
getting it because they're doing things like
what Rudy Giuliani and Angelina Ellis have
been doing and people wondering, is she going
to get the same privileges, Rudy?
And getting checked into a top notch hospital
for observation as a precaution.
Chris Christie was able to do it.
Of course Trump was able to do it.
I have no idea.
But what I can tell you for sure is that so
many Americans would have survived the virus
had they been able to do the same thing, many
of whom were behaving far more responsibly
than Rudy Giuliani and Jenna Ellis.
I mean, tragically, there are people who.
Wear a mask every time they leave their home,
work from home, do nothing other than go to
the grocery store and they've got the virus
and some of them have died.
They didn't have access to this type of treatment.
Rudy Giuliani flies around the country waging
a bogus voter fraud case, shutting down the
Arizona state legislature due to exposing
those folks.
And he just gets to check in and get the absolute
top treatment.
You know, it's part of that two tier system
that we talk about.